i mean i got tons of records i made
after the album was done that
um
but right now i'm like working on some
some other [ __ ] that's not my [ __ ] um
and uh that's what's happening now but
this this year when you say not your
[ __ ] what do you mean just like
um
[Music]
uh just another i can't disclose too
much but is it music related yeah
[ __ ] super group
um no it has nothing to do with like my
name i'm just
it's been this trip has been a trip um
are you helping write for kanye or
something
um i don't know
um but
i want to make a lot of music this year
was that a nice like shot in the dark
that might be accurate no okay i just
gotta ask because i feel like every time
someone comes to la they end up writing
for kanye west randomly in a studio
session and it's like oh [ __ ]
so you're writing for yay that's big
that's big donda two bars down to two
bars huh
i'm gonna make so much music this year
hey so when kanye reached out to you man
like did he dm you or did he like did he
get in touch with your people so much
music this year is gonna be so good
knowing yay changed your life what's it
like working with him
i do love yay's music have you met let
me just ask you this have you ever met
kanye west
that's a fair question right without
revealing anything have you ever met the
guy
yes
and is he in was he nice yeah did you
meet him recently
dude i'm so
everything i'll make so much music it's
gonna be so good man the yay [ __ ]
token record is gonna be crazy